thank you
I have my own voice and as undocumented
and not being able to do my political
power is as strong as
this week the masala woman he loved it
I see yes like a nice room Pender's
because you make I was young okay when
felicidad a lot of people don't know
where to go to get registered the
majority will be Hispanic families that
are citizens and are able to vote and
just becoming citizens but don't know
the whole thing so I take my time while
canvassing
I want to make a change in my community
I want an impact in the community and I
think just say it and I can share memes
on Facebook maybe some boat
but if actually I don't go out and we
get people sign up and educate them on
this then that change is never gonna
happen
you